salut à tous c'est christophe pour la
chronique politique en ce moment on
parle beaucoup de l'unef le syndicat
étudiant à cause notamment des débats
sur la place que doivent prendre les
théories postmoderne dans les recherches
universitaires ce débat cristallise
surtout autour de la notion assez floue
l'islamo gauchisme qui est en grande
partie incarné par l'unef et notamment
depuis que sa présidente avoué sur les
ondes d'une radio que son syndicat
organisait de temps en temps des organes
des réunions non mixtes à savoir en
mixité raciale et personnellement j'ai
milité il ya quelques années dans le
milieu étudiant
puisque j'ai repris des études sur le
tard pour ceux que ça intéresserait j'ai
fait une vidéo d'ailleurs sur ce
parcours universitaire alors je n'ai pas
milité l'unef un jeu militer à sud
étudiant une organisation plus à gauche
qui est fédérée à l'union syndicale sud
solidaires mais j'ai pu voir et entendre
des choses sur l'unef voir les pratiques
au quotidien ce syndicat est donc je me
disais que ce serait intéressant de vous
faire une sorte de vidéo de retour
d'expérience sur la question alors tout
d'abord quelques remarques préliminaires
quand on parle de syndicats étudiants en
fait on fait un abus de langage
le syndicat juridiquement c'est quelque
chose d'assez spécifique qui regroupe
des travailleurs est en fait ce qu'on
appelle syndicats étudiants sont en fait
des association de loi 1901 qui dans
leurs statuts et bien mettre en avant la
défense des droits et des acquis des
étudiants mais c'est un abus de langage
de parler de syndicalisme également
l'unef n'a pas toujours été ce qu'elle
est aujourd'hui
à une période l'unef et est une
organisation apolitique c'était une
fédération nationale qui regroupait les
corporations c'est à dire les
associations de filières droit sciences
humaines etc
et c'est réellement transformer en
syndicat entre guillemets c'est à dire
avec des revendications sociales et
politiques
après la guerre d'algérie qui a
énormément politiser les étudiants à
l'époque ce qui avait notamment le
service militaire et donc la question
d'aller faire la guerre
gérer pour les conscrits et à partir de
ces années 60
l'unef est devenu une espèce d'auberge
espagnole de tous les courants de gauche
et d'extrême gauche
il ya longtemps été tenues notamment par
le pcf les maillots etc et également par
par les jeunes du psu parti socialiste
unifié qui était l'équivalent peut on
dire à de la france un sourire ou du
mouvement ensemble aujourd'hui
mais avant cela et bien l'unef était
juste une association étudiante comme
d'autres d'ailleurs pour l'anecdote un
jean marie le pen a fait partie de
l'unef puisqu'il était président de la
corporation de droit dans sa fac je
crois que c'était assas corporations de
droit qui était fédérer et l'unef
donc jean marie le pen si on veut faire
de l'anachronisme a été membre d'un
syndicat étudiant islamo gauchiste
maintenant je n'entends à mon expérience
personnelle avec l'unef
cette personne s'était expérience n'a
jamais été très agréable puisque alors
déjà en soi les milieux étudiants sont
politisées sont des milieux assez
particulier puisque ce sont des milieux
qui tourne en vase clos
ce sont comme disait mitterrand de en
parlant du mjs donc le mouvement des
jeunes socialistes rattaché au ps ce
sont des écoles du vice on apprend pas
mal de manoeuvres bureaucratique de
guerre intestine etc et c'est assez vrai
de l'unef particulièrement d'ailleurs de
l'unef qui a connu pas mal de scission
justement après la période soixante
soixante huitarde et qui n'a été
réellement réunifiée qu'au début des
années 2000 puisque des années 80 vous
années 2000 où globalement vous aviez
deux ou trois unef qui chacune en fait
étaient rattachés à un courant politique
il y avait une unef qui était plutôt
liée au parti communiste et une deux
autres qui était plutôt liée au courant
de gauche du parti socialiste
alors c'était assez compliqué vous aviez
les pros emmanuelli les pros julien dray
et c est moi ce que je retire de
toute cette période de syndicalisme
étudiant c'est que réellement ces
milieux sont de véritables écoles du
vice parce que ça touche les milieux
étudiants donc quand on fait des
manoeuvres politiques hard ou des coups
fourrés de toute façon ça se voit pas
les générations étudiante se renouvelle
extrêmement vite en deux trois ans on a
des nouvelles têtes donc les gens
oublient tout vous pouvez faire autant
de conneries que vous voulez et puis ça
ne porte pas à conséquence ce sont dans
des milieux étudiants on touche pas à la
grande politique
globalement ça reste en vase clos et
puis vous avez cette tolérance aussi
également des autorités universitaires
qui globalement part du principe que il
faut que jeunesse se fasse
on voit bien avec le peu d'expulsion de
fac enfin deux des solutions clients
quand les facs sont bloqués alors pour
ce qui est spécifiquement l'unef
alors moi j'ai milité à tours on n'a
jamais réellement eu l'unef à tours on a
toujours eu des gens qui étaient des
représentants mais on n'a jamais eu de
gens réellement politique parce que
c'est un syndicat mais globalement ce
sont les gens qui font vivre ces
syndicats sont des gens qui sont aussi
encarté dans les mouvements politiques
dont qui ont un bagage assez important
on n'a jamais réellement eu personne sur
tours c'est à dire qu'on avait des gens
qu à tous 5 et dès qu'il fallait signer
un tract dès qu'il fallait faire quelque
chose en fait
ces personnes téléphoner au bureau
national je sais pas si c'est comme ça
dans toutes les facs de taille moyenne
mais nous il n'y avait pas de résistance
réelle de l'unef
il y avait une existence physique mais
alors pour ce qui était de l'existence
cérébrale en fait
le corps physique à tour été relié au
cerveau par téléphone au bureau national
apparaît également il faut savoir que
l'unef
dès qu'il ya un mouvement étudiant se
met finalement en tête de gondole et
nous rappelle qu'elle est le premier
syndicat étudiant en france et c est
souvent joue les porte-paroles des
luttes il faut quand même savoir que
l'unef dans ces milieux enfin dans ses
mouvements de l'ugtt ne représente
absolument rien
les syndicats étudiants ne représente
quasiment rien numériquement même l'unef
qui se dit un premier syndicat des
étudiants de france par exemple nous à
celui des étudiants on étaient 400 à 500
est pas au niveau local au niveau
national à tours on a eu à certaines
périodes jusqu'à en quasiment une
trentaine de personnes de l'année
syndiqués mais c'était par des réseaux
affinitaire etc et des réseaux enfin des
gens qui militent est réellement par
exemple on n'avait qu'une dizaine une
douzaine maximum alors sud étudiant
était quand même beaucoup plus petit que
l'unef
on reviendra sur les pratiques
d'adhésion de l'unef après il faut bien
comprendre que globalement et
syndicalistes étudiants entre guillemets
c'est à dire des gens de gauche ils font
du associatifs étudiants revendicatif
ces quelques milliers de personnes au
maximum en france
donc là tellement ces gens ne pèse rien
dans les luttes jeu généralement les
gens qui sont dans les manifs étudiantes
ou qui bloquent les facs
ce sont des gens qui ne sont pas
encartés qui sont patients à ces
incontrôlables et de fait les directions
réellement des luttes étudiantes ne
passe pas par les syndicats ils n'ont
pas directement mais par les
coordinations étudiantes donc ce chaque
assemblée générale étudiante nomme des
représentants pour faire une assemblée
générale nationale
donc on appelle souvent des
coordinations nationales et qui sont des
lieux épouvantable de luttes intestines
entre tous les différents courants
politiques et syndicaux qui peut y avoir
dans les facs grosso merdo chacun
localement essaie de faire nommer parmi
les représentants
des membres de son courant politique ou
syndicale et ensuite ce qui fait que la
coordination nationale est un véritable
fourre tout où tout le monde se bat pour
faire voter ses émotions et l'unef
notamment dans ces moments-là profite du
fait qu'il n'y ait certaines facs qui ne
sont pas en lutte et bien pour dire ah
bah nous on vient de cette fac là pour
représenter pour la représenter à la
coordination nationale est en fait
souvent ce sont des gens de l'unef qui
se sont auto mandaté à partir de fac où
il n'y a personne pour pouvoir peser
nationalement alors qu'eux ils sont
incapables de faire vivre des mouvements
localement alors ça se sont pas les
seuls le npa au site à ces spécialistes
ce genre de choses c'est à tel point que
parfois d'ailleurs ça donne des
coordinations sont contrôlés par un
syndicat et d'autre part un autre ce qui
fait que c'est assez peu lisible
au niveau national ces dernières années
d'ailleurs à ce genre de problème entre
qui représentent réellement les
mouvements étudiants entre les
coordination nationale où les syndicats
se pose de moins en moins puisque l'unef
s'est réellement effondré donc même
symboliquement été plus capable de tenir
ce rôle de porte parole également
d'ailleurs on va revenir là sur la
question du nombre d'adhérents l'unef
l'unef en fin de compte c'est difficile
d'avoir les chiffres mais moi il ya
quelques années on me disait c'est au
maximum sept à huit mille militants s'il
faut bien faire la différence entre les
militants et les adhérents
il faut savoir que l'unef à des
pratiques que personnellement je trouve
absolument dégueulasse excécrable au
niveau de l'an carthage tous les ans
donc vous avez des inscriptions à la fac
et les étudiants notamment qui vont
inscrire en l1 doit venir physiquement
déposer leur dossier
début juillet il ya cette occasion les
associations et syndicats étudiants
généralement tiennent des tables de
presse et d'information pour se faire
connaître
l'unef bien sûr ne déroge pas à cette
règle et profitent de ces de cette
période où les gens viennent s'inscrire
et notamment les l1 sont complètement
perdus et ne savent pas comment
fonctionne la fac pour et bien encarté à
tout va et à nous sur tours c'était
assez assez horripilant puisque il n'y a
jamais personne de tours qui tenait les
étapes de presse systématiquement ses
dirigeants de paris du bureau national
qui venait cependant globalement cinq
jours toute la journée et bien essayé de
vendre l'unef en tenant des discours
absolument mensonges et en plus nous on
était souvent juste à côté donc qui ont
ce parti c'est pendant toute la journée
les discours extrêmement vendeur est
alléchant l'unef
grosso modo ces gens avaient un espèce
de de tram a récité extrêmement
commercial où ils se présentaient comme
étant une grosse association qui faisait
vivre la fac et qui organisait les
soirées étudiantes la solidarité
étudiante les partages de cours enfin
bref ce que fait ce que font une
traditionnellement les corps pourquoi là
les corporations
sauf que c'est absolument faux l'unef
chez-nous n'existait pas et ils encartés
comme ça des gens plusieurs je dirais
plusieurs dizaines sur une semaine en
leur faisant signer un chèque de 20 0 et
en leur promettant à la d'être une
association qui serait là pour les aider
pour animer la fac et c'est le moment
venu sauf que c'est absolument faux
puisque c'étaient des gens qui venaient
de paris pour faire des cartes et rien
d'autre donc ça c'est une pratique qui
est assez exécrable tu peux vous assurer
qu'on la subit pendant plusieurs jours
de suite alors que soi même on fait une
table d'information ou au maximum on
prend les contacts des gens et on
nous clairement on avait décidé de pas
faire dans carthage comme ça parce que
ça on trouve que c'est une pratique
commerciale déloyale clairement pour moi
c'est une forme d' arnaque
et bien je vous assurer que c'est
insupportable au bout de d'une heure ou
deux déjà vous avez envie de les claquer
et je sais que certains camarades
s'était pas passé très loin parfois d'en
venir aux mains tellement tellement
c'est dégueulasse d'entendre ce genre de
discours absolument mensonges et tout le
temps et donc la force de l'unef qui se
vante d'avoir je crois qu'au moins dix à
quinze mille 15 mille adhérents
peut-être le seul et bien en fait il
faut bien comprendre que globalement les
adhérents que fait l'unef tous les ans
ce sont des gens qu'ils ont un petit peu
à qu'ils ont sur vendus entre kim et
l'unef
moi personnellement à titre individuel
c'est qu'on frôle l'escroquerie quand
même et ça ça crée d'ailleurs quelques
problèmes puisque par exemple il
organisait une bourse aux livres où il
prenait les livres des étudiants pour
les vendre à leur place et le problème
c'est que comme il ya personne chez nous
à tour de redorer le représentant de
l'unef et bien une fois que les
étudiants venaient récupérer leur pognon
il trouvé porte close et du coup ils
venaient nous voir nous pour nous
engueuler nous expliquer qu'il fallait
qu'on leur donne l'argent sauf que nous
fabriquons nous mêmes et nous on n'est
pas l'unef
allez voir l'unef vous êtes faire
arnaquer donc voilà pour une pratique
qui était constante au cours d
cinq ou six années où on a tenu des
tables de presse était systématique
c'était toujours des muros les
bureaucrates de l'unef venu du national
qui faisait ce petit discours est
systématiquement en kart est sur un
discours totalement bidon extrêmement
bien marketé mais qu'ils n'avaient
aucune réalité et dont on peut se
demander s'il ne relève réellement pas
de de l'escroquerie également d'éditer
leurs le syndicalisme étudiant le milieu
étudiant c'est l'école du vice et sa
touche notamment sur une question
particulière qui est la démocratie
étudiante notamment un des acquis de mai
68 ça a été la démocratisation de
l'université au sens démocratique un peu
au sens de l'ouverture au plus grand
nombre avec notamment l'élection divers
élections dans les ufr au niveau
national et serra et il y a notamment
les des élections nationales au cnous
donc la structure nationale qui gère les
crous c'est-à-dire tout y est les
oeuvres universitaires ce soit les
résidences étudiantes ou les bourses
pour les étudiants les moins fortunés et
donc il y a dans le conseil
d'administration
du cnoss des places pour les étudiants
et ces élections périodiques et bien
donné lieu à des magouilles absolu pour
ce que j'en ai entendu comme ce niveau
national c'est difficile de juger mais
moi de ce que j'ai entendu puisque ce
sont des enjeux bien sûr symbolique
entre présentation
quand on se dit premier syndicat de
france il faut pouvoir montrer qu'on a
des élus mais aussi sur des questions
financières
il faut savoir que ces élections et nous
donne accès à des financements et pour
ce que je me rappelle c'est et 7500
euros aux associations par élus donc on
est quand même sur des chiffres qui
commence à être assez importants et ces
élections et bien moi parce que j'ai
entendu donné lieu à certaines
magouilles notamment par exemple et bien
des disparitions de bulletins de vote
pour défavoriser l'ennemi etc et où
parfois des pratiques extrêmement
bureaucratique où on faisait invalider
les bureaux de vote et les bulletins de
vote des autres parce que il n'ya pas la
bonne typo il n'ya pas le bon logo c'est
pas exactement le canonique l'on dira
par rapport à ce qu'il faut et c'est
donc des luttes assez bureaucratique et
judiciaire en fin de compte tours pour
des questions du pognon et
personnellement ce que je retire de ses
années étudiantes que je j'ai toujours
été assez critique puisque
personnellement j'ai commencé les études
sur le tard à 23 ans donc j'avais déjà
un petit peu d'expérience c'est que
réellement ces milieux étudiants l'unef
mais aussi tout ce qui est associatif et
quand même souvent des milieux
relativement pourri sont à ces
pathogènes
un point de vue politique ce qu'ils
apprennent quand même à des jeunes à
faire souvent des magouilles à tasser
bureaucratique politicards c'est à mon
avis le problème des organisations de
jeunesse on laisse des jeunes entre eux
donc
avec le niveau hormonal des jeunes quoi
qu'on en dise et qui donc ont souvent
l'impression d'avoir la vérité absolue
et de faire valoir cette vérité absolue
hélas hélas pour l'unef mais pas que
puisque aujourd'hui toutes les questions
sur l'islam au gauchisme cristallise
autour de l'unef mais on pourrait parler
de sud étudiants mais aussi de tous les
milieux étudiants d'extrême gauche qui
sont très vastes
y a pas forcément besoin de l'unef pour
faire des réunions raciale non mixtes
comme on avait vu lors d'une occupation
de la ctc la sorbonne il ya deux trois
ans et très honnêtement je garde un
souvenir assez mitigé de ces années un
souvenir assez dégoûté de ce que pouvait
être l'unef qui est vraiment vraiment
pour le coup je me répète mais vraiment
l'école du vi qui permet à des jeunes de
s'exercer à la politique la plus
politiciennes qui soit sans aucun
scrupule d'ailleurs ça c'est quelque
chose qui est assez qui m'a assez marqué
ce que sont les gens on leur apprend à
faire de la politique notamment sur la
question des ans carthage comme ça
extrêmement un extrêmement mensongers et
on apprend à ces jeunes à faire de la
politique mais un politique avec un
petit p politique manichéenne ville
celle qui qui est faite de magouilles de
manipulation de manoeuvres d'appareil
et le pire c'est que ces jeunes s'en
délecte globalement puisque l'une est
fait quand même notamment l'unef
quand même un espèce de gloubiboulga de
toutes les tendances de gauche et
parfois on a quand même l'impression est
bien qu'il y a espèce de jouissance à
dans cette jeunesse a magouillé à
manoeuvrer à avoir l'impression de faire
de la grande politique dans un champ qui
en fin de compte ne porte pas à
conséquence
mais qui leur donne un bagage et des
pratiques pour plus tard qui elles
pourront avoir des conséquences dans des
milieux politiques plus bien plus plus
institutionnelle
enfin du moins plus en contact avec la
société civile également pour ce qui est
des questions post moderne un petit
point dessus alors à l'époque j'étais
moi c'est gérer tes l'achat et 4 5 ans
bien 4 5 ans les questions post moderne
était à peine en train d'apparaître au
niveau 1 au niveau des facs
donc je n'ai pas vu ce genre de
questions liées l'unef
par contre ce qui m'a toujours surpris
notamment quand les bureaux ce second
appel bureau c'est les bureaux les
petits bureaucrates soit une info
ailleurs quand les bureaux de paris et
genève
j'ai toujours été surpris de la mixité
ethnique de ces gens et ça m'a toujours
posé question parce que non il ya un an
syndicat d'extrême gauche donc
antiraciste machin tout ça très porté
sur ce genre de choses et on avait des
gens qui étaient non blancs mais pas en
proportion particulièrement importante
par rapport au reste de la population
quoi et pourtant déjà à l'époque parce
que pour les plus jeunes d'entre vous je
vous assure et pour moi continuer à
aller à la fac notamment pour la
bibliothèque universitaire quand j'ai
des vidéos ou pour le plaisir de la
lecture en cinq ou six ans on a vu une
transformation
ethno culturelle on dira des facs
notamment de l'être beaucoup
d'apparitions de filles voilées ce qui
était peu présent dans les années
jusqu'au début des années 2010 et donc
pour en revenir l'unef
dès cette époque début 2010 j'ai été
surpris de voir que parmi les bureaux ce
qui venait de paris il y avait toujours
au moins la moitié au moins la moitié
qui étaient des non blancs et je me suis
toujours posé la question de comment ces
gens faisaient pour avoir autant de non
blancs parmi les gens qu'ils envoyaient
surtout plus en plus c'était le bureau
politique un bureau national donc des
gens qui sont formés politiquement etc
je demandais comment il faisait pour à
réussir à attirer autant de non blancs
aujourd'hui encore je me pose la
question alors est ce qui leur tenait
déjà un discours l époque postmoderne et
non l'a pas vu ou bien est-ce qu'ils
revendaient un discours en mode oui tu
es non blancs à des rats l'unef c'est un
moyen de promotion sociale etc ou bien
est ce que c'est juste le fait que à
part sur la région parisienne une
proportion des non-blancs plus plus
importante qu'un reste de la france je
pense pas que ce soit quand même 50 % je
sais pas mais je sais que c'est des
choses qui m'a toujours intrigué de voir
ces personnes sur représentés la l'unef
et je me suis toujours demandé si ce
n'était pas aussi une forme de dents
tendu tacite entre les blancs et les non
blancs de les faire entrer parce que ça
fait un petit peu mixité ethnique et
puis pour certains signes se dire comme
ça tu es un un petit peu la minorité de
service et ça peut te permettre de
grimper après ensuite dans la hiérarchie
politique et cetera plus facilement
parce que on a besoin de couleurs
honnêtement ces questions je suis
toujours posé j'ai jamais eu de réponse
sur ce 1 sur ce point mais ça aussi
probablement contribué à ce que l'unef
adhère assez vite à toutes ces théories
et postmoderne notamment au niveau
raciale puisque effectivement si vous
avez la moitié du bureau politique
national qui est constitué de non-blancs
fatalement d'un point de vue culturel
les personnes sont certainement plus
enclines à adhérer à ce genre d'idée
donc voilà pour les petites remarques
que j'avais fait elle avait à faire par
rapport à l'unef au syndicalisme
étudiant un milieu dont notamment la vie
il faut s'éloigner si vous êtes étudiant
même de gauche c'est pas la peine ce
sont des milieux où on apprend la
politique politicienne plus que la vraie
politique
bref en tout cas j'espère que cette
vidéo vous a intéressé
si vous même vous avez eu des
expériences vous avez vu l'unef en
pratique et bien
n'hésitez pas à faire part de votre
expérience dans les commentaires parce
que c'est le genre de choses qu'on
retrouve pas dans l'est notamment quand
on parle de syndicalisme étudiant l'unef
et cetera dans les articles des
journalistes parce que c'est le genre de
choses que les journalistes ne peuvent
pas voir par définition que seuls les
gens qui ont milité ou qui ont été au
contact du réel peuvent voir donc c'est
intéressant si si vous les partagez
votre expérience dans les commentaires
et sur ce serait bien je vous dis
à la prochaine